[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes le président
valéry giscard d'estaing quitté hier le
pays qu'il a aimée et le peuple qui l'a
servi il part en des temps tournante est
victime à son tour de ce mal contre
lequel nous luttons et qui a bouleversé
le monde
mon choix pour de la loi première ce que
vous avez voulu structurer la vie
politique autour de deux grands partis
sans changer le mode de scrutin qu'on
n'allait pas changer le mode de scrutin
ne marchera pas deuxième raison c'est
que vous n'avez pas profité de la
création de l'ump pour vous débarrasser
des vieux barons et ne donnait pas au
spectateur l'impression que le président
connaît les questions à l'avant non sans
s'être est censé combler donc je connais
que les rêves
bonsoir bada bonsoir mais je peux faire
de belles affaires de niro qui mute
jusqu'à abattre à tout dire ok midi de
nero cumul giscard qui me de bourvil
c'est pas prévu on est ce à quoi je me
lance
j'avais l'idée de tracy vrai de dire mon
texte de vous lever
w et de partir sur un échec la pente
était à trois mètres et on l'avait vu
jeu pourquoi d'ailleurs a dit m quinze
bêtes devant la porte ce qui a créé ce
temps apple mais oui alors c'est trop
long que moi mon parcours c'était dire
au roi
vous vous levez wll sortie c'est tout au
revoir la toile dit au revoir à valéry
giscard d'estaing avec cette séquence
devenue culte au fil des années en
chuchotant ou en silence avec tous ces
juifs partagés aujourd'hui pour saluer
la mémoire de l'ancien président mort à
l'âge de 94 ans sa longévité était
devenu une blague récurrente comme sur
ce compte qui twittait depuis deux ans
chaque jour sur sa bonne santé certains
s'amusaient même pas l'imaginer candide
en 2022 ça va se passer en 2021 où la
lune pourrait peut-être accueillir les
cendres de vos proches cela peut sembler
complètement dingue mais une entreprise
américaine propose une sorte
d'inhumation lunaire concrètement
celestis c' est bien embarquera des
urnes funéraires sur une fusée la fusée
vulkan et si tout se passe bien et bien
le pur à disperser ces cendres à
l'endroit même où neil armstrong a
marché en 1969
est-ce que c'est là où se faisait
guillotiné les gens je sais pas je ouais
je veux plus que ça à bâtir
la place de la bastille non non non je
crois pas encore c'est mes regards comme
c'est beau j'ai un obélix
alors cette aventure poétique au
cosmique vous coûtera tout de même douze
mille 500 $ et c'est pas la peine de se
presser car le premier vol est déjà
complet il ya plusieurs profils qui sont
attendus des passionnés bien sûr
d'astronomie mais aussi de l'auteur
arthur si clark octobre britannique qui
a d'ailleurs écrit 2001 l'odyssée de
l'espace donc vous le voyez il n'y a
finalement pas de mystère
bah
la glace
singapour qui autorise la vente de
viande artificielle oui du poulet sans
poulet qui sera bientôt proposer des
cartes des restaurants de singapour des
nuggets élevé en laboratoire par une
start up californienne 1 développé à
partir de cellules animales
les autorités de singapour estime que ce
produit est propre à la consommation
et cette première mondiale ne serait
qu'un début il ya des dizaines de start
up qui travaille déjà sur la viande
artificielle 20000 fibres musculaires
pour un soft est caché les chercheurs
ajoutent ensuite de la chapelure pour la
consistance du caramel du safran et du
jus de betterave pour la couleur et
voilà le fameux burger in vitro
après trois mois de culture et un prix
de revient de 245 milles euros
voilà du boudin pour le dessert bien sûr
j'ai prévu le dessert typique anglais la
jelly jeu laissez moi même c'est pas
compliqué un peu d'eau chaude un peu
d'eau pâtes du sucre un peu de colorant
un peu de jus de fraise et je vois les
deux autres coûts entrants bien gérer
mes prothèses et eroglu en fait tu fais
pas des films et même toile en fait
c'est juste que tu fais là mais tu vas
dans le dernier nommé si tu regarde même
pas franchement dépêche toi déjà calme
toi parce que tu vas les composites soul
mais calmez vous c'est un jeune est là
pour s'amuser mais apport le rapport
avec les policiers qu'on en parle en ce
moment mon rapport mois et policiers ça
va mais qui prend pas de risque non le
problème c est ça peut vous étonner mais
il ya des crs qui me saluent dans la
manifestation mais l'as bram
excusez moi ce sont des pourritures mais
non non non
elle engage in engagé l'abrapa va pas
s'attaquer mais non moins célèbre à tout
le monde et pas au courant
la brave c'est la brigade d'intervention
adrien sur la violence violente et ce
sont que des gens mais qui sont ils vont
me faire dire des choix qu'ils mangent
arrête de nous [ __ ] la trouille
chocolat est
loquace non tous qu'ils interviennent
les braves bâtiment bat dix mois contre
qu'ils interviennent les braves il en a
eu 17 dans le temps ils jettent dans le
temps bon il ya un regard d'un homme
[Musique]
bien avec sa cause de ségolène royal à
qui l'ont arrêté
ouais c'est s'abrutit les enfants tout
cela
maintenant il ya les tablettes résultat
aujourd'hui maintenant c'est sûr les
plus abrutis ils en font qu on regardait
dorothée ou ségolène royal
j'adore paris les monuments ses
magnifiques l'architecturé très belle
mais savoir qu'est ce que c'est qui et
quoi ma chance j'ai pas ouvert les
vivres moi c'est l'équipe de 6 à la
maison qui depuis le 20 octobre dernier
travaille comme des dingues dorment
assez peu pour vous servir vous proposer
cette dalle émission il se nuit valéry
giscard d'estaing cours de transport
boon et pathé
salut simon surréaliste hier merci de
nous avoir
on sue à musique un mental
[Musique]